[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i'm gonna start with some background
and um
i can't give you all the history of the
middle east region in a talk that's this
short but i want to give like a brief
framing at least to help introduce us um
to the things that are relevant to the
talk
and then i'm going to talk about the
memes that i analyzed for this paper how
i did that analysis
i'm currently also writing a guide on
how to study memes so it's really
important for me to make my methods more
transparent and let people know what my
process was and how they can also do it
themselves
and then i'm going to tie that analysis
to
memes as mapping tools and what this
concept means what are what its
implications might be
and after that we'll open it up for
discussion so please know that you'll
have time for questions
so an important question to start with
is
what is a meme
there are many definitions out there i
use le more schiffman's definition i
find that it's broad enough yet specific
enough to work with
a limous schiffman defines means as
a group of digital items that share
common characteristics of content so the
things that are in them what they look
like
their form the way that they look
think about like text does it have text
does it not have text
and stance
um which could be defined as the feeling
that they convey or the mood that's in
them
and they were created with awareness of
each other so they're sort of in
conversation with each other they're a
group
a meme cannot be just the one a singular
thing
um
and uh they're circulated imitated or
transformed on the internet by many
users so so that process of
imitation and transformation is
necessary so with imitation there are
parts that are supposed to be kind of
the same
but with transformation there there's an
editing process that goes there you
change the caption you might copy
some parts and edit other parts
and many users is left here um
kind of vague on purpose
because
you know a lot of us are in some like
chat groups that have maybe three or
four people
and memes start to circulate there so
many users could be a really small group
of people
but we also all know memes that go viral
and are shared by thousands or millions
of people
so many users can be a lot of different
numbers
one example
is the distracted boyfriend name
which some of you maybe have seen
floating around the internet i brought
three examples here today
so as you can see
um
the content the image is the same and
all of them it's imitated in all of them
the structure is limited is imitated in
all of them um but part of the content
is different so in the one on the top
left
me
is distracted from work by literally
anything else
in the one on the top right
me again distracted by the groceries
that i bought
with a
30 pad thai that can be delivered to my
door i feel like we've all been there
um and the one at the bottom
specifically dedicated to heather
maybe your cat uh is distracted by the
very uh fancy castle that you got for it
that probably cost a lot of money by
literally any cheap little box
um
okay
and the means that i focused on um in
this paper specifically
are images
but i also wanted to stress before i dig
into this that memes can also be videos
we've seen videos on maybe tik tok or
videos like music videos like gangnam
style or even dances like the harlem
shake we've seen those turn into memes
memes can also be a sentence who here
has said or heard somebody say
thanks for coming to my ted talk so
that's an example of a meme that's
simply a sentence so they can take many
different forms
and means have been used across the
world both to reinforce and disrupt
power relations
indigenous activists in australia for
example use means to bring together a
movement against the erasure of
indigenous people and raise awareness
about the ways that australian
colonialism has been enacted over time
in china internet users deploy creative
content including word play memes
parodies to express political dissent or
criticism and participate in what's
become sort of a community ritual
within the arabic speaking context
specifically scholars have shown how
memes can be used as tactical social
actions whereby the sub-altern uses
means in their struggle towards justice
i've also talked previously in an
article uh in the international journal
of communication
about memes being part of a general
cultural push whereby youth use this
type of creative online content
um to interfere in the direction of
global cultural flows
and these theorizations of the political
and cultural impacts of internet means
inform my analysis of digital culture as
an extension of offline culture rather
than seeing the internet as a separate
space
in fact power relations from the
so-called offline can also be reproduced
online
so iframe means as
digital culture artifacts that are
created and circulated in a way that's
deeply connected to the social ties and
the cultural and political experiences
in the everyday lives of the people who
create them
it's especially the case in the context
of palestinians who have been living
under prolonged colonial rule war
continued civic unrest etc that that's
the separation between online and
offline becomes even more muffled
in this paper i argue that
memes can be conceptualized as mapping
tools that chart out the connection
between cultural political and spatial
boundaries
and participate in a playful negotiation
of these boundaries
i think this framework is particularly
useful for investigating memes in
circumstances where space culture and
politics are under constant change and
negotiation
so i give the example of palestine here
but i think there are many contexts
all contexts maybe where uh this type of
framework could be useful
palestinian mean makers
specifically
navigate the dynamics of living under
settler colonialism
global capitalism and marginalization at
the local and global levels as well as
their own cultural concerns
people want to talk about palestinian
diversity gender equality and youth
issues maybe that have to do with
generational differences
being a student in a different town
popular culture that they're fans of
although new media technology
are built on the assumption of
connection through disembodiment from
space
space is actually central to their form
and their content
scholars on digital culture and
palestine
problematize the assumption that new
media technology will bring with them a
democratizing promise
palestinians have used new media
technology to recast ideas of access to
land and space through for example
creating online tours of al-aqsa mosque
or digitized oral history and archives
this use is important for palestinians
and other indigenous communities across
the world
where colonial power enforces a
disconnection from the land through an
erasure of the history of indigenous
cultures connection to that land
this limits access
of indigenous people uh to certain
places and segments the indigenous
population
new media technology
in this way become part of a larger
matrix of power
in which palestine's borders are
continually constrained
israel's get expensive and the european
unions get fuzzy i'm drawing here from
how the wheel stories work
on this specific triangle of power
um hellgata wilsori writes
from the perspective of palestine a core
contradiction arises as a backdrop
against which to understand information
communication technology infrastructures
the containment of palestinians in
narrowing and disconnected spaces
occurs at the same time
that high-tech globalization is positive
as the route to openness through which
to overcome the fragmentation and
containment in other words
new spatialities and bordering
mechanisms are created while others are
eradicated
by outlining the ways
that borders are simultaneously expanded
and controlled
in the advent of new media technology
tawil suri demonstrates that
as she puts it the technological is
spatial political and the spatial
political is also technological
this technological spatial political
relationship which is what i'm going to
call it for short
is manifested online through
vague platform policies discriminatory
artificial intelligence on platforms
like youtube and facebook for example
amal nazar who i think i
have here wrote about this
palestinian youth also use seek talk to
connect with each other and promote
their own culture but a lot of times
they get met with backlash in comment
sections or even get their accounts
removed from the platform
so the experience of palestinians
on social media platforms tends to be
sort of a mixed one where they're able
to form community and celebrate their
culture
and do creative things uh on one hand
but at the same time they receive much
backlash either by the state by online
trolls or platforms themselves
and what i wanted to see is where
where do memes fit in this technological
spatial political relationship
what are they doing for people who make
and share them and what do they do in
the space specifically of
mixed cities
so to answer this question i focused on
three instagram pages
um two meme pages from mixed cities that
are situated in the north of israel
haifa means and nazareth means
and uh one more page that's dedicated to
life on the inside that doesn't mean
jail the inside refers to the borders
that were established by israel in 1948
in case you're not familiar with the
term
um it's called idaho in arabic and um so
that page's name is mass on the inside
which is where i drew the title for the
article
and all of these three pages have
thousands of followers and posts
regularly i kind of wanted to engage
with
meme accounts that are active
and popular
and i chose the latest 50 relevant memes
from each of these instagram accounts uh
to analyze
uh but uh posts that weren't relevant
were removed so the way that i
determined what's relevant is um
posts had to be considered a meme so if
there is simply like a screenshot
sometimes name accounts will post like a
screenshot from the news or something
like that
and there was no process of imitation
transformation
or something like that so that wasn't
considered a meme
so i dropped it from the corpus
in addition i also filtered out posts
that focused only on topics that were
not relevant to the
um spatial political relationship that i
was looking at so there were a lot of
posts because of the timing of when i
wrote this there were posts about covet
19 that were just about like wearing
your masks under your nose or over your
nose so stuff like that that had nothing
to do with the context outside of
covet 19 or mask wearing that didn't
mention any specific group or culture or
city or politician or something like
that i removed those posts they were
likely also copied from other accounts
but i had no way to determine that
um
but yeah so if post is passed covered 19
but within the context of people's
relationship
to
culture to the state to the city itself
than those
i left in
and people often often ask me about this
so i
went ahead and
shared
this image here to explain
that in my process here i included the
visual part so the image part of the
meme
or for those folks who are at home
you can see it on the right side of the
screen and i also included the caption
that at the bottom
the rationale behind this was that the
text was often
not edited onto the image it's like it's
much quicker if you
screenshot an image and then instead of
having a caption on the meme
you just use the caption below so there
were some names that were image only and
the caption
below had to be included because
i didn't want to miss out on
any commentary or a lot of times that's
where the better the joke was
and for my analysis
i based it on criteria that came up from
the memes themselves as well as from the
academic literature on digital media and
space in palestine some of which i
mentioned earlier
and the criteria noted things like
places like
towns neighborhoods cities countries
cultures and subcultures that were named
in the means
politicians celebrities any figures that
appear or are mentioned in the mean
languages that were included and other
keywords that helped me identify
recurring themes
and for i have two notes kind of here
very briefly related to the analysis
that i understand space as kind of
socially negotiated and socially
constructed this is based on doreen
massey's work
and means as a geographical concept
which can be used as a methodological
tool that's
suited for the analysis of popular
culture discourses that transform social
practices in spite of their apparent
superficiality and
triviality so here devi johnson is
talking about means in general not
specifically internet means
but i use this concept to kind of
connect it to how
space is socially negotiated and means
can be part of that negotiation
i organize the data based on three
themes which we're about to go into but
i'm going to give like a brief kind of
overview to for you all to see the meta
picture
of these three levels the themes aren't
always mutually exclusive so i kind of
organized the data but they can also be
there are means you will see that might
belong in more than one
and first we have the global level that
reflects how
they navigate and intervene in global
political
and seeing that the timing of this
analysis so when i was writing this it
was like
december january
february and then like i did revisions
later but the article was already
written and the data was already
collected
and
because that coincided with the global
covert 19 pandemic
and there were certain like big global
events such as the u.s brokered
agreement between israel the uae and
bahrain
it's not surprising that there were a
lot of memes that commented on sort of
these things that were happening around
them
the second level is a state level where
i examine means framing of issues that
involve local um
institutional politics so with the
israeli state the knesset again there
was also like
um
ongoing elections there was a series of
like three or four elections in a row
that were happening at the time that i
was collecting the data and the third
level was that was angry palestinian
diversity so this level looked at the
ways that palestinian diversity was
reflected through the means
both in terms of how means as a group
portrayed a diverse group of people
but beyond representation it was also
about what intentional steps people took
to emphasize that cultural diversity and
invite people from different places
people with different dialects to join
in on the meme conversation
and this is the part where we're gonna
dig in and the part where we're gonna
see a lot of memes so if you're here for
that
this section is for you
um
okay
so we start with navigating global
dynamics and many means reference u.s
politics and popular culture and
sometimes these things also intersect
right so reflecting uh this reflects the
dominance basically of the us on the
global cultural stage
it's not surprising since u.s
institutional politics directly impact
the politics in palestine israel and the
larger region
and the way that this came up
is that many names use images
of u.s politicians in funny like mashup
content or for the purpose of just
participating in a certain mean trend
so the burning meme went viral after the
original image was taken during the
inauguration of joe biden as president
and here we see bernie
wearing his mittens we can barely see
the mittens because they've been
replaced
by the palestinian kusuyu
and this meme was accompanied by a
caption uh in arabic it was
which means like it's super cold
literally means it's
cold as dogs but
that's it just means it's really cold um
other memes also expressed lack of
confidence in u.s politicians both in
their uh impact in our own countries or
here
and in the possibility of them having
and
halting the empowerment of oppression
locally so former u.s president donald
trump was a common figure in these means
um which is also not surprising like i
think we've seen less trump means and
less
trump tweets
since the election they kind of toned
down but at the time that i was doing
this work they were still circulating
and trump was still tweeting i believe
um so this mean for example on the left
uh it says
um
it's like a fake tweet it fabricates a
tweet so this isn't a real tweet that
donald trump shared and it says you can
take all the status and all the profits
just let me have the homeland
and the caption then said i am a citizen
but this you know is sarcastic because
it is uh the exact opposite of what he
practiced during his time in office and
the meme on the right
uses trump's tweet to stop the count
to kind of make fun of um what happens
on a night out when you see the waiter
calculating your bill
and i think this was specifically about
downtown haifa
and the normalization of israel's
relationship with bahrain and the uae
was another global political issue that
came up in the means
memes created periodical scenes mocking
their relationship and emphasizing their
lack of access to enjoy the perks
that it might provide certain people
the texts in these in a lot of these
memes uh and captions repeated that they
meaning the mean makers or meme
circulators can't afford a trip to dubai
themselves and they also made fun of
haifa's so-called rocket building
which looks a lot like
dubai's burjalara which is a really
famous hotel in dubai
but i have a picture coming up next
so here we have i'm gonna move this for
folks who are in the room
um
so we've got people making fun of
they're making fun of themselves too
right there's like a comment on class
status here and on money uh if you can't
afford to travel to dubai you can take
haifa's light rail and go to downtown
where you can see the ministry of
interior that has this building that
really resembles dubai's
uh uh dubai's burjalarab and this image
is of of an emirati person
when they come to haifa and they see
this building they're really mad
and this is kind of again
mocking kind of a class difference and
uh
um
who has money who doesn't have money um
so it says when you start a night
in downtown haifa and finish it in dubai
and for those who aren't familiar so
this is haifa
and this is dubai so the buildings do
look a lot alike
uh and this has been like an ongoing
kind of mockery thing
since the building was built in the
early 2000s i believe
an important thing to note um
to notice about
the dominance of u.s culture in neem
culture
is that what it does it makes it so that
participating in meme culture
necessitates a level of fluency in u.s
popular culture
and this necessity for fluency in u.s
culture is exemplified in the use of
trending memes so we saw the birmingham
donald trump stuff
but also there are a lot of memes that
use movies and
television shows so people need to kind
of be acquainted with whatever is
trending
in the us moon culture but also in us
popular culture and politics in general
so there are a lot of memes that use
like
the office uh i don't know i can think
of like the spider-man name where is
pointing
there are a lot of
game of thrones memes etc
on the other hand though despite u.s
culture kind of having that dominant
status it's also notable that many names
mix languages and cultures and although
u.s cultural fluency is a prerequisite
for participating in meme culture
mixing english into arabic wasn't really
encouraged in fact the memes kind of
drew a hierarchy of languages that
intersected with class and gendered
connotations
so
colloquial palestinian arabic
dialect was put kind of as the preferred
choice
as the mean speaker's class choice
and
fusha also known as modern standard
arabic was portrayed as the hipster
choice or the overly intellectual kind
of snobby choice
if anyone in this room speaks or is
learning arabic just fyi this is what
the meme makers say it's not me
um mixing english was portrayed in the
memes as being either classist or trying
to associate with a higher class
so whether you're making it or not
um oh i don't know
it was also portrayed as less masculine
and so was mixing hebrew mixing hebrew
was mocked as an attempt to
overcompensate or sometimes was
associated with fragile masculinity or
kind of trying too hard
ultimately palestinian makers use of
global political and cultural content
and means
reflects kind of their positionality the
place where they stand
while it's also a way for them to
intervene in that reality and rethink
that hierarchy and place themselves
within it
they reassign meanings to the cultures
and politics that they are consuming but
also creating
it's a way to understand or make sense
of the space around them and the
cultures around them but also to move
between these cultures and these spaces
so the lack of confidence in politicians
that i mentioned at the global level
extended itself also to israeli state
politics including palestinian members
of the kenneth as well
when it came to israeli political
figures like former prime minister
benjamin netanyahu who was still prime
minister at the time that i was doing
this work
means pointed to a type of hypocrisy
whereby politicians in general reach out
to palestinians for votes but without
taking any actions to improve the
situation of palestinians living in
israeli cities or towns or neighborhoods
on the ground
the memes express the deficiency in
resources and infrastructure that impact
the palestinian community
this name addresses it in haifa
specifically citing the different
treatment and resources that
palestinians in neighborhoods like abbas
and what
from the municipality these are
predominantly palestinian neighborhoods
which is
at the very bottom here on this window
um it's a historically palestinian
neighborhood
and on the other side of that we have
neighborhoods like
a predominantly jewish israeli
neighborhood that are getting sort of
the better treatment of the municipality
and again i want to remind everyone that
when i was writing this
um just to give some context the state
of israel was headed towards its fourth
election in two years
then prime minister benjamin netanyahu
had won the past three elections but
only by a margin
and nearly failed to create a government
coalition between different parties
and much of this process is kind of
reflected in the means there are memes
like about
voting about elections about campaigning
a series of memes pointed um
directly towards netanyahu's efforts
they talk about netanyahu
how he intends to milk arabs
and play games with people and attempt
to lure some palestinians into voting
for him or to trick them into voting for
him
so we have this meme on the left here we
see an image of netanyahu
i think you can see more clearly like on
the instagram account itself for some
reason the screenshot didn't capture
that word very well but
he's playing soccer on the beach and it
says i'm gonna play ball with you or
like i'm gonna use you to play ball um
and on the right here we have a game of
chess
where
i think the key piece here is
like a mispronunciation of assalamu
alaikum i think there was a speech that
netanyahu gave where he tried to say
hello in arabic but it was
mispronounced
and so mean makers are kind of mocking
that effort that like oh with a single
misspelled word you think that you're
going to trick people into voting for
you
and that's not it memes also expressed a
lack of confidence in palestinian
members of the israeli commission
many of them of those members were
portrayed in a mocking or periodic way
this was especially the case for the
joint list of
an alliance that was formed in 2015
between uh parties that have a
palestinian majority in the knesset it
was sort of a strategy that maybe if we
create a joint list that has all of
these four palestinian majority parties
maybe they will get kind of a better
seating in their in the knesset
um
so memes were used to criticize certain
knesset members point to their
inauthenticity and hypocrisy
the example here shows mansur
a common figure in the memes
was named allah there were like a few
folks who were named a lot
uh this guy mansoor abbas separated from
the muslim party his muslim party from
the joint list that was created in 2015
and he's portrayed a lot in means as
someone who's willing to go to extreme
lengths just to gain political power
even if that means betraying his own
people's interests
and here abbas is criticized for posing
up to netanyahu's family and doing
whatever netanyahu asks him to so here
we have netanyahu his wife sarah and
their son yeah here on the magic carpet
and
some more context of like since i wrote
this thing
mansoor abbas split from the joint list
completely
and he created a united arab list that
actually is only his party
um and this
this party was
instrumental to forming the israeli
knesset coalition in june of 2021 so he
kind of stayed on brand and actually
ended up helping form the current
israeli government coalition
memes also raised issues concerning
cultural erasure so we already saw kind
of this mean there was a spoiler alert
earlier
they commented on the practice in which
zionists appropriate foods like hummus
and falafel and um
the one here kind of reflects this
long-standing tension
that rises from claims of hummus and
falafel as israeli food
using an image from the january 6
insurrection
in the u.s capital
this brings me to the third section
uh navigating the palestinian experience
and cultural diversity
so memes also express the diversity of
palestinian culture and subcultures
within that culture
as well as common experiences of
palestinian youth and by youth i mean
the people who are creating and
circulating the means
if i have to guess their ages i would
say it's
maybe 16 to
30 something
like early 30s
a recurrent theme for example consisted
of memes that were mainly concerned with
the student experience a college student
experience
many palestinian students leave their
hometowns or in four universities in
cities like haifa tel aviv or jerusalem
or even to
study abroad jordan is like a very
common place for people to go study
or jeanine in the west bank
and they return to their own hometowns
on the weekends
and they refer to it as invalid which
just means a town but that's how we
refer to our hometowns and honestly a
whole paper could be written about these
like
university versus balad memes or the
student experience memes people
commented on the difference between
their town and their university town
they share experience like
looking for apartments in a crowded
inexpensive city
living on a low budget shopping online
on a low budget asking parents for money
every week or doing laundry at home
which i also did in college
and memes show how youth make sense of
these different cultures that they are
navigating and the cultures that exist
in each one of the universities so here
we have an example on the right
pointing out how people dress in haitha
university versus a kind of less hormone
dress that's uh common to the technique
i went to the hebrew university i'd say
it was more on the technion side of
things
and here we have bernie sanders i think
a lot of us saw this meme it's from the
bernie sanders campaign
and here you have kind of a university
student going home and to ask their
parents for money yet again
and means also included captions that
are calling on people from different
places around palestine acknowledging
not only the diversity of the followers
of the specific meme account and the fan
base of the new account but also
the mobility of people within palestine
and how they move around palestine
they write kind of shout outs to people
from different cities or towns using
their local dialect inviting them to
participate so for example i'll give an
example of the town of kofor panna so
like people would say like hey like
where's the people where are the people
of course
like tell us how you say this phrase or
something like that
and the caveat i'll mention here is that
not all means are like disrupting
oppression and creating an inclusive
environment there's really it's really a
mixed bag i definitely saw some memes
i would say that they're a minority but
they did exist that were sexist and
homophobic these types of names kind of
mocked women commenting on like makeup
habits
how people posed for photos and other
kind of stereotyping
portrayals
some memes associated being gay with a
lack of masculinity in a way that can
reinforce toxic masculine and homophobic
attitudes
and there are also kind of cultural
rivalries that came across in the means
so here we have the haifa university
versus technion rivalry there's nazareth
versus haifa um
[Music]
karma neighborhood that we saw earlier
versus downtown and kind of pointing to
different um
comparisons
and these comparisons highlight what
kind of i already alluded to a little
bit before that these memes are both
reflective and also function for
navigating these spaces so who gets to
go where or how should you behave when
you go somewhere
so in this meme we see someone from
nazareth
and
if they go how they behave in order to
fit in if they go to haifa so this meme
basically portrays the process of code
switching by using uh these dog means so
on the left side we have a person from
nazareth when they're in nazareth so
they're the small dog the larger and
more muscular dog um
and they're using like heavy nazarene
slang
saying things like i'm telling you i'll
beat him up
and then when the when the person from
nazareth goes to haifa they become
smaller suddenly they're mixing english
using words like vibe and downtown
and again portrayed perhaps as less
toxic masculine um and more uh trying to
confirm with and conform with the
environment that's surrounding them
memes as mapping tools then chart out
the social stratification and indicate
where the boundaries are drawn between
different social groups and subgroups
within the group of palestinian youth
they tell us how people from these
different subgroups might experience
space when they move in it and who gets
to go where in mixed cities in addition
they show us who holds power to decide
regarding mobility and regarding
resources and infrastructure
mixing popular culture and current
events
means connect livid experience
of culture
to the discourse that's around it and
create an intervention in it
i suggest memes as mapping tools that
introduce their consumers to the lay of
the land culturally politically and
spatially speaking and allow their
producers to comment on and intervene in
those spatial and political dynamics
memes draw out not only the different
spaces of neighborhoods cities
and the world but also map out the
social stratification related to these
spatial politics answering questions
like who can and can't navigate these
spaces easily or smoothly
who holds power in these spaces
who decides where resources go
or to present some more concrete
examples some more concrete examples
based on the means that we saw
who owns downtown haifa on a thursday
night
who is and isn't welcome
in downtown
which neighborhoods in haifa are
thriving which ones are drowning
how does a person from nazareth need to
act in nazareth and how do they need to
act in haifa
where do palestinians stand on the
chessboard or the soccer field of
israeli politics
means made by palestinian youth in
israel map out the cultural and
political terrain showing where they
stand on this map their positionality in
a complex web of cultural politics and
political dynamics
and how they move within that cultural
political and spatial landscape
their precarious citizen status
which i talk about a little bit more in
the article if you're interested
is also reflected in the complex
experience that's mapped out through the
means that they make
which demand deep knowledge of the space
the languages dialects
culture and subculture
ways to behave and navigate the space
smoothly where to go for better
resources or to find spaces with people
who have similar values
the urban spaces of haifa and nazareth
just like the rest of the region region
are continually changing and being
contested
both haifa and nazareth are rich in
palestinian history and cultural life
although these cities are technically
mixed
housing both israeli jewish population
and the palestinian population the
neighborhoods remain largely segregated
in the recent few years polly withers
writes about this i can't remember if i
put a quote
why not spoil
um
in the recent few years in haifa notably
there has been um
a process where middle middle class
youth are kind of refashioning urban
spaces into enclaves that's center
palestinians and their culture and where
israeli jewish citizens are considered
gusts
and so means are part of this larger
process
the meme content from these mixed cities
is in line with narratives that break
what's been labeled the missus
coexistence
wrote in the new york times recently
about this myth that palestinians and
israeli jews and mixed cities are a
model for coexistence
the means that i looked at here draw a
picture where palestinians and israeli
jews do not spend time together in the
same spaces and do not receive the same
rights or infrastructural resources
the means in this corpus makes popular
culture from different parts of the
world and some of them notably mixing
cultures and languages becomes a way to
celebrate or point inwards towards
either problems or issues within
palestinian culture itself
popular culture that's coming
predominantly from the us then
is oftentimes used or deployed as a
means for navigating the local cultural
landscape
it's usually at this point that i ask
what's at stake
so the conceptualization of memes as
mapping tools
acknowledges that means are implicated
in the relationship between the spatial
political and technological
i think it's this side
bear with me almost done
um memes as mapping tools helps us draw
the connection between digital culture
to space and life in cities
the conceptualization of means
as cultural mapping tools also
complicates the idea that new media
technology is going to necessarily be a
liberatory force
or a democratizing force
this framework can show us how mean
meme culture is simultaneously creating
new possibilities for inclusion and
celebration while it can also reinforce
existing systems of oppression as we saw
with the examples that reinforce sexism
or homophobia
but new media has been and still is also
leveraged
to combat the segmentation that's
enforced by settler colonialism
using means as mapping tools can allow
us to assess where that cultural
segmentation stands at a certain moment
in time and from a specific cultural
perspective
what these memes accomplish here is
carving out room for palestinian youth
within these cultural spaces that are
difficult to navigate
or where they experience risks or
limitations
memes become part of that process that
paulie withers talks about
of refashioning urban spaces into
enclaves that center palestinians and
their culture
so they use digital culture vernacular
as part of a larger cultural shift to
make room for and maintain the
connections across palestinian culture
for example by inviting participants
with different accents and from
different towns meme makers push for
recognition of palestinian living
experience and hold space for their
cultural diversity
the memes map out palestinian youth
aspirations for their culture politics
their desired values they draw hard
boundaries when it comes to politicians
israeli or palestinian or global
that are promoting settler colonialism
and working against their interests
they point to a clear direction of which
they think justice would look like
having fun with cultural diversity
equitable distribution of rights
resources and a stop to colonial erasure
and cultural appropriation
so some final thoughts to close
um
on a personal note kind of this is my
first time writing about haifa this is a
city where i grew up
um and i was writing about it as i
mentioned during covert 19 pandemic
where didn't seem to be a prospect of
visiting there were a lot of memories
that came up during that time a lot of
important political
things that were going on
and those things can make the writing
process very interesting so i just kind
of wanted to throw it out there because
i recognize that i'm not the first and
definitely not the only one who has a
personal experience like that
and just wanted to make that process
less invisible
and as i mentioned this article has just
been published in information
communication in society so please check
it out if for any reason you don't have
access shoot me an email
it's part of a special issue that they
just published about memes and politics
so if this is a topic that interests you
in general there are plenty of cool
papers to check out
um and kind of where this to talk about
where this work might go in the future
one is um i will continue to explore um
means that are made by palestinians i
think this is a very important area to
study there's a lot of complexity there
it's not an area that's been explored
and a lot has happened again since i
wrote this december january it's kind of
crazy to think how
within you know the uh big turmoil that
went on i think started in april may was
that when it was happening and then june
there was elections and things kind of
continued to happen and change all the
time
and so the memes also change there are
new trends and new things to write about
so i do think about publishing a
follow-up article and your questions and
ideas today might help
carve out the direction that that might
take
and for people who are thinking about
names as mapping tools i might also
recommend kind of a more narrow focus
both for myself and for you
since this paper was kind of the first
one on palestinian means i went and
explored the accounts
as is
and covered so many different themes and
so many different small ideas here and
there and i think now that i'm reviewing
it i'm like oh each one of these can
actually
benefit from
being focused on and being kind of the
sole topic could be a paper on its own
so the message that i would want to
leave you with today is that memes and
digital culture in general are part of
our space
they're in a in relationship with our
space going back to that
um
technological spatial political
relationship so how do we make sense of
this relationship i'd be interested to
see for example what image of the world
do memes draw
how could they now how could they
dictate what where we go in the world
or other ways that technology is used to
reinforce and depress and disrupt
oppressive power dynamics on the ground
and again i want to end by thanking
everybody for listening
thank you andrew i think we made it
through
and
we'll open it up for q a now but i'm
gonna um put my email up here
if uh i know we have some folks online
as well if you feel like
reaching out um please be in touch
thank you
[Applause]
um welcome justin
we just do this together okay
great so we'll take a few questions from
the room while the people online should
feel free to type their questions in the
chat and andrew will flag us when we
have some good ones um but uh i mean
that was terrific i think so thank you
so much
what questions that we have in the room
to start with
um
i wonder
how we can understand the effect of
routines you know or or how i mean i
know it's really hard to know the kinds
of effects there are but i wonder what
we might point to or there's some ways
i agree they're political they're
certainly map cultural boundaries uh
gender we see
national state politics global politics
um i've often wondered though that given
the kind of snarky
attitudes you know that does that kind
of undermine a little bit or or you know
i know starkey could be pretty political
too uh it doesn't necessarily
make it not political but there always
be a bit of a distancing that goes on
with the snark
aspect of it um
and then oh it's just you know oh it's
just a joke or i'm just being funny or
you know and and so
it's so that's sort of the general
question of and i you know i agree that
they are political but but i can also
imagine the
criticism that they're not that
uh or they can't really have that but
just click ism and slack but whatever it
is so you know it's not it's not real
political action you know the old school
um so that that's the question and part
of it too is do you talk with the people
who interpret these names you know we
didn't get a lot of voices of people who
say oh yeah when i saw this game it
really it did this for me or did that
for me and that might be a way of giving
you know leaving a little more meat on
the bone for what kinds of reactions
people have besides you so that's sort
of and i'm asking as
yeah so yeah i'm wondering about that
thank you oh well first it's nice to
meet you for i think this is our first
time meeting um and uh okay the first
part of your question was sort of about
the effect of means and i think it's you
know this is the the
business of uh like proving causality
right and it's hard like unless someone
tells me like i did this because i saw a
meme and this was the main reason like
before that i had no idea i was gonna do
it and then i did it and this hasn't
happened to me in an interview yet so i
cannot prove causality but kind of the
wider question of thinking about are
they political or are they not i think
this is also up for negotiation like i
define politics very broadly and for me
like participating in culture and
being part of a cultural shift you know
you're pushing you might be not you know
you might not be pushing in like a super
strong way but you're sort of pushing a
little bit and to me that is
political especially that
a lot of people might be navigating a
very sensitive kind of area where
either their own safety or their work or
something
might be at risk so that very small push
is also kind of
political um
but i know that's for some people
political is you've got to be outside
with a sign um
and so and some of those people are
doing both like i
maybe not in this case specifically i
don't know like um those memes those
name accounts specifically are anonymous
like i've uh
not been able despite being from haifa
and it's like a small community i
haven't been able to crack
who is doing haifa menus see what you
guys find out let me know
um
but i've done interviews for my
dissertation and i agree it's
interesting
things come up um a lot of times it like
maybe confirms what i'm thinking or
gives me new ideas
sometimes there are ideas that like keep
coming up that i'm like trying to push
away and then i'm like okay i'm gonna
have to deal with this like a lot of
people talk about memes as their own
language or universal language i
remember working on my dissertation kind
of trying to steer clear from that like
lingua franca metaphor
but people kept mentioning it so i like
okay this is what people are saying then
this is important um but i am
since those memes meme accounts
specifically were anonymous i kind of
didn't want to
you know broach people's anonymity
without their consent in any way
thank you
um
um
um
me
yeah um thank you for that question um i
think well one is like my positionality
in this case i think it really helps me
understand and interpret
especially writing this while like not
being able to be there physically and
writing about space i think is
interesting
um and
in terms of um bringing memes to a
different context so in my work like
context is really important so i do a
lot of contextualization when i'm
writing that was kind of one of my beeps
with review or two in the process of
writing this article is like i'm giving
as much contextualization as i can
especially in a region where things are
changing constantly so i'm not trained
as a historian at all i don't really
have that skill but i was trying as best
i can to capture like that's why i keep
saying like
it captures what was going on in the
moment
and even though this is a meme that you
can still go to the account and you can
still see kind of the timing of when it
was posted and when it was shared is
also important
and
even now kind of the context that i was
giving throughout that's not the article
that since it was written
also matters of like okay what ended up
happening like what do we know now that
we didn't know then
so i i understand that for someone who's
not familiar with the context it can
kind of be
a little bit disconnected um
but i think it's you know they're worth
exploring because they also teach us
about either other places other contexts
other ways that names are used at the
end of the day i'm not the historian of
haifa like at all
and my goal is to really look at digital
media um and
to really understand it i think it takes
stepping out of kind of the
dominantly familiar things um
so yeah that's my take on it but one of
the things that you showed us in the
memes was i mean some of these memes are
i mean they're global so they're
universal like you know the sort of like
uh i'm looking over the burning meme or
yeah like the
distracted boyfriend distracted
boyfriend seems like particularly
universal like all human beings get
distracted by things um or even the sort
of baby drowning who turns in the old
person under the sea yeah but it seems
like part of what happens in the means
is you take these things which should be
universally recognizable and then you
add some kind of in-joke to them that
that that renders it somehow only
partial to like a very small group of
people yeah
like what's the appeal what's the appeal
of taking something universal and making
it
um like why not just make your own
intros what's the what's the draw do you
think of
that kind of
i mean it's a kind of funny thing to
take a universal thing and make it only
funny to you know whatever 12 people in
high five or that kind of thing yeah um
i think you know like those memes
actually like uh those accounts have a
um
bigger following than some of the things
that i explored for my dissertation so i
think actually looking at memes that are
maybe not necessarily trying to go viral
like i interviewed people who are like
i'm not really trying to have more
following i made this account because i
was sending my friends memes on a chat
group and they told me well why don't
you make this account
and then slowly more people start
following them but again there's a
limitation right especially with the
culture mixing because if you're looking
at a burning name that is mixing arabic
for example and a lot of times it's
spoken arabic so it's specifically the
palestinian dialect
um
that might be like understandable to
people in like the levant like broadly
defined
but that's still like kind of a limited
group of people and if you take in
having to know the politics having to
know the space the ones that are about
like downtown and things like that like
it keeps narrowing down the audience um
but i think that is what sometimes tends
to make it more funny for those who get
it there's a certain amount of like
pride i think that we get when we get
the joke and we know that others might
not get the joke
um we feel smart i think you know i'm
again i'm not a psychologist this is
just like out of instinct of thinking
where it is but in terms of um political
power i think that there is a power move
in deciding who's included and excluded
because when people are editing an image
they're making decisions like this is
not you know maybe they're not thinking
about them taking days writing papers
uh but they are making decisions of like
oh should i put english in here should i
not like should i put this in a nazareth
accent or in a
more like broadly understood accent so
there are these are kind of decisions to
include and exclude so to me like that
is a power move
um
and i think you know looking at that
looking at python names along with kind
of the
cultural like urban like nightlife and
music scene that's been developing that
is kind of trying to create this like
separate um
safe space almost for palestinian life
uh looking at these together i think is
really interesting
is
[Music]
so i'm just curious about what's next
with that are we going to continue to
develop that or get trained
so i'm hoping
am i the hope um
i i do plan uh to publish maybe within
the next year or two kind of a follow-up
article
uh continuing to think about
means um as like creative digital media
and their relationship to space uh i
feel like there's there's more there
there uh and i think palestine is like a
great example for thinking about this
because space is so contested and things
are moving um fast all the time
and uh
even though like i will be i do plan to
draw like in the future more from
architecture or urban planning or like
the critical side uh from there because
my work is interdisciplinary so
if you have recommendations do let me
know uh so yeah i think there will be
more coming and
if this topic is exciting for you i i'd
love to hear more from your perspective
as like someone who knows architecture
um so
that's just more questions about your
insights about the uses of the language
the first one is how you write the
conclusion of our user's priority
language uh we kind of made interviews
um
uh like if english becomes like
the use of english and political
yeah uh thanks for that question so
the to answer like the method thing is
like a lot of times um
with um because names use like a caption
that's in english so if it remains in
english and remains as is
uh to me that's like it's part of the
name um and so that's maybe where it
falls into like
cosmopolitanism and things like that
where it's not like oh i'm gonna use
english for this one but if you think
like maybe as an opposite example um
of uh the meme that had like the guy
from nazareth when they go when they go
to haifa and suddenly they're using
english words deliberately so then there
are words like vibe like downtown like
those are words that don't necessarily
have to be in english knowing again
knowing the context i know that we don't
usually say those in english
um in haifa specifically and so there's
an element there that
you know a lot of it is like the method
is like feeling out like is this a
common thing um does it seem like is it
an intentional thing is it called kind
of the overall message
and
a lot of what i like end up saying comes
from recurring themes so i gave like
very few examples here but the sample
size was 150 names
which you know would be my pleasure to
just like go through all of them with
you but um would probably not make a
very good presentation in the end so if
i see something that is constantly
happening then to me that's like a theme
that is coming up
let's take a question here
yeah so we're going to do maybe two to
let's go to the chat so early on in the
presentation um
there's a question that came in from
professor antieco in umass amherst
asking why is there a difference between
cultural popularity of paradising
linguistic diversity slash code
switching especially around youth and
linguistic differentiation
um
is this a disconnect
from um
i'm thinking about this i need an
example
i think i need a clarification if like
the disconnect is coming through in um
this work specifically or like a
disconnect um
culturally speaking or like speaking on
the towards the context itself okay um
clarification
so it's here to
um
ask uh welcome to the neighborhood
oh carlton
in other words i'm seeing the most
popular means or the most reason
oh good question um so the memes that i
focused on here specifically are
the most recent 50 that are relevant so
there are a few here and there that were
deemed not relevant as i explained
before
um based on their either content or if
they're not a meme but i use the most
recent 50 and those are definitely
especially with the nazareth means
account and the haifa names account
i know that those are memes that were
created kind of by
these instagram users
the other account
mess on the inside
might have been
using and reusing uh certain trending
memes but um they're mostly i would say
as original as a main guess uh in terms
of that they were created by these
instagram users
um
interesting
yeah um so i would say that there were
there um were more conversations
happening about that on some of these
name accounts
since kind of the events that the game
began unfolding since march april may
like
um with all the protests and
you know the more that the content
becomes political the more likely it is
to be censored by instagram in some ways
and then when it gets censored we
usually see like um people who own the
account uh trying to speak up about it
uh
um
this is not true for the accounts that i
am using here at this time but there are
name accounts that say in their profile
description here's my alt account
and so they have already created an alt
account by using maybe the same username
and adding like a number or something
like that so they have like an
alternative account in case this one
shuts down that are like all of their
fans are already following them on the
other one
um
and regarding kind of the cross
pollination between
different platforms
so um
one of those pages also has a facebook
page and that posts the same things
um uh there isn't like
for
palestinians i would say are not
palestinians that are situated in
palestine i would say are not using
twitter as much as facebook and
instagram especially as a source for
memes
um so i did kind of choose instagram
despite having like a couple of these
pages on facebook
because it was where like things felt
like they were happening you know that's
where things are posted and shared and
um
um i also looked at like where they had
more followers
not as a measurement but like as part of
the larger picture like where is there
more activity happening
um
yeah
i think i got positive questions
thank you
oh
and thinking about the mapping of the
means themselves i was curious it really
brought out how much memes are operating
with the kind of thing of relationality
between different parties yeah i was
curious it seemed like there's a few
kind of recurring
formal structures there was
the
yeah now i'm thinking also of the meme
of like um the hi-fi infrastructure meme
where you see like the skeleton that's
drowning at the bottom and then the baby
swimming at the top kind of the mother
helping one of the babies but not the
other um so there is something to the
structure i think you're talking about
like a visual structure as well as you
know
um that helps kind of deliver the
message i didn't compare the structures
uh i'll be honest but i i appreciate you
asking this question because i think
it's a great idea to look at
kind of how what the structures are
doing
uh to kind of deliver this message um of
relationality that i talked about
because i think there's a there there
like there were a lot of you know a
versus b like we saw with um dog name
with the nazareth
the way people dress in haifa university
versus the technion like there were some
of these memes that were comparing i
think
that was definitely like a repeated
format um but when it comes to the chess
one and like the ones that are more
complex uh i do think that i would need
to look back at the means and see if
there is kind of a repeated pattern
though
paul's question
may you think vanilla which i was
actually
thinking about which is also sort of
mythological like paul sort of proposes
like oh you just did something really
cool here that i could take to all these
other different sites um but your also
work is also really local um in
particular like of the sort of methods
you're using to examine these things
what do you feel like you would feel
comfortable telling a bunch of graduate
students like oh yeah go and try this
because it'll probably be useful in
other places and what feels like more
particular to the examination
you know of one city that you know
really well
at this particular point of time i mean
go and try it in other places
um
but uh always consider the the ethics of
the work that you're doing uh what
you're bringing and taking from this
space
your positionality as i mentioned um in
relation to the space
um i am i would be really curious to see
people using kind of means as you know
for to like how they map out the culture
um of boston or mit like there are so
many things that can be done and
so i think the local examples are used
um you know like they're they're useful
for understanding hyperso but this
really my goal is like to understand
digital media better and to understand
how digital media can
facilitate a certain relationship to the
space or not um
but yeah and i will say that uh knowing
the context really well and providing
context if you're writing providing
context for your readers uh considering
that as part of your method and part of
your ethics i think is really important
so
yeah
yeah so we have a question from
professor jim carrey here
he writes i still remember the trump
golf and me on the border and i play
through
it slightly for sure but the visual
objective position is hard to erase
i wonder about the power of these images
just to positions and the almost
instantaneous hard to capture essence at
the moment can you say a bit more about
how means are unpacked
i simply means like how means are
unpacked as part of my method
um i mean my answer to that would be
like what we were just talking about
which is context so
um
understanding like when that name was
born like where this image was taken i
think this is especially important with
memes that are pointing to a certain
type of uh politics or political
relationship because you know like if
we're going we go back to distracted
boyfriend name where it's like
me like you know getting distracted from
work like that is a universal and
repeated uh kind of behavior that many
people can recognize but if we are
thinking about
trump at the border or that immediately
made me think of the name with netanyahu
playing soccer on the beach um so
unpacking kind of the context of
this was during election time uh here is
the strategy that netanyahu was known
for uh here is what uh people who um you
know um
were writing maybe either like in the
news or on social media like what the
discourse was kind of around that event
overall so context plays a huge role
here
when we see that m posted a response
oh yeah that mixing english and arabic
is not really encouraged
well what i meant by that is
like in the example where
we see
the guy from nazareth going to haitha so
mixing english in that way and this is
also i think it answers anne's question
like it's not necessarily the arabisi
example which is like mixing english and
arabic together as the same words or as
the same grammar but rather using
english words as a way to relate to
maybe a higher class or try to perform
so anything like it's uh the
authenticity is really important here so
any hint of kind of a forced type of use
that might indicate some sort of like
inauthenticity or trying to associate
with something that you're not really
reading as you are
is kind of discouraged to say the least
it's like
mocked often
you are
part of that for that
like no situation um
if you are part of well this is where we
need to go to the audience the analysis
um and do some interviews i think the
way that the main portrays it is mocking
it so i'm going to pretend that i was in
a class that liked to mix unnecessary
english words into my language that is
not practiced
among maybe like working class or lower
class people
then i would say if i saw meme that was
mocking my behavior i probably might not
agree with it but that's just based on i
guess
um
this makes me want to like take the same
name and just like ask different people
how they respond to it i think that
would be great
time for one more question
[Music]
good fourth
are like are divisive like it's less
than that
um and um and the one donkey showed like
uh
it was like technion
i can imagine like people on both sides
of that sort of like interpreting that
in different ways it's like
it could be divisive but it could also
be like you wanted to take either
perspective i would like to look at the
first on the right
like is there is there a sense that
there's more that are sort of like aim
to divide then sort of like
allow some multiple entry points into it
like give a lot of people take their
perspective
i'd say like speaking about these
accounts specifically or the names that
i looked at
very specifically um i you know i don't
think that there are more memes that are
divisive these could be read in a
decisive way but i think for the most
part it's like oh true like they really
you know there really is that type of
cultural difference
and the goal is really to make people
laugh and participate rather than kind
of be like you shouldn't dress this way
um especially this was especially true
for two of the main accounts again the
third one is the one that sometimes had
like homophobic or
sexist type of portrayals um they were
not very common but things like oh you
know like this is how girls like to take
pictures um kind of mocking the way that
like women might pose um or do their
makeup or whatever so
those i would probably label as like
among maybe the more divisive group
good well thanks for a terrific talks a
lot thanks everyone for a great
conversation and thanks andrew for
facilitating and thanks everybody online
for joining us